y yo
yo soy dios
de verdad soy dios ss ss en serio que
soy dios
y la verdad es que soy actor y estoy en
una obra donde hago adiós los fines de
semana y hoy les quiero platicar de las
cosas que me han sucedido siendo dios de
las sorprendentes reacciones que he
recibido haciendo este personaje y saben
que hay en cuenta de que estas cosas que
me han pasado tienen una conexión con mi
vida que yo nunca hubiera imaginado
a lo largo de la temporada en el teatro
no ha habido una sola función donde no
se me acerca una persona o varias al
final a decirme cosas como ay eres dios
es que tengo algo que pedirte ya como es
si te pido que ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
tiempo mi cosa es muy sencilla no o
alguien que medio en broma medio en
serio me dice a ver dios yo tengo cosas
que reclamar te
u otra que aunque me halaga me ha dejado
frío en más de una ocasión
si dios fuera como tú volvería a creer
sas
y yo creo que me ha pasado ni una ni dos
y tres veces lleva más de cien funciones
y lo más sorprendente es que la gente me
lo dice con una candidez impresionante
no puedo dejar de pensar
la brutal necesidad que tiene la gente
hoy en día de creer en algo de creer en
alguien
ahora debo decir que mi dios no es el
dios más tradicional del planeta no nada
que ver con esa idea del dios viejito
pachón citó en su nube bueno bueno hasta
la náusea no mucho menos no con ese dios
furioso que juzga y que señala con un
dedo flamígero para ahogar que la culpa
eterna nada nada nada vidrios medios es
mucho más coquetón no mucho más
alivianado
mucho más humano creo yo
mi dios medios está fuera del contexto
de las religiones muy respetables todas
entendiendo entendiendo la religión como
un compendio de preceptos de dogmas de
fe no que te dictan maneras de decidir
de hacer de creer obviamente
y a veces de amar o de testar
pero lo que es muy curioso es que estas
reacciones donde la gente se brinca la
convención de la ficción donde no se
cree que es teatro pues me han
acompañado a lo largo de toda mi carrera
la primera el primer episodio que yo
recuerdo claramente de un caso de este
tipo tenía yo 21 años y estaba yo
haciendo una pastorela de revista en el
teatro blanquita ni más ni menos
los arcángeles en la bonita lógica
revistera pues éramos el mago ari sandy
y yo
sin conejo blas obvio y la estrella de
belén era la legendaria tongolele ay no
más en fin para nosotros el cuento largo
a mí al final de la función me tocaba
este clásico texto que reza gloria a
dios en los cielos y paz en la tierra a
los hombres de buena voluntad vestido
con un frac totalmente blanco brillo
citó igualito al del señor rol de la
isla de la fantasía que sé que
cuarentones aquí que si se van a acordar
de que les estoy hablando pues un
domingo de esos una señora muy humilde
se cuela
a la parte de atrás del escenario con
sus dos niños 11 como de 3 años y el
otro de 6 7 más o menos y con toda la
timidez del mundo se me acerca
y me dice
señor angelito
le podría dar usted la bendición a mis
niños es que ya van a hacer su primera
comunión
y yo me quedé helado
tenía 21 años y me saca de onda durísimo
no esté yo obviamente me disculpé con la
señora muy amable súper amable con el
señora y me disculpé con él y gpu no
señora sabe que yo soy un actor no yo no
puedo hacer eso por favor discúlpeme
y que se me suelta llorar a moco tendido
a la señora
devastada desesperada bueno yo voy a
hacer y entonces esta señora lloraba y
lloraba y lloraba y se acerca en
viéndola llorar tongolele y su marido
don joaquín supongo cero que un señor
como de 198 no negras así este tamaño
también porque lloraba la señora y la
señora les dice
y el angelito no quiere bendecir a sus
hijos que seguro son malos y por eso no
quiere
y que se voltea conmigo y me jala para
un lado yo con tremendos ojos y me dice
mira el muchachito tú le vas a dar la
bendición es un niño como tenía la
señora y hablamos después y no puede
hacer eso yo no soy un actor yo sólo soy
un actor sí pero eso ella
no lo sabe así que ándale
pues lo hice como supe como pude y según
yo desde el personaje no
y bueno la señora se le iluminó la cara
vuelta loca de contenta fascinada los de
ellos dos como que no entendían mucho la
verdad es que no más sonreían de ver tan
contenta su mamá pero ella la señora
ella necesitaba creer
ella necesitaba creer que las cosas
podían estar mejor aquí y ahora ella
ella necesitaba creer que un ángel podía
ser de carne y hueso y escuchar su
petición y responderla
ella necesitaba creer en algo real
creer
en alguien
crees en alguien
para mí
ese espacio esa necesidad de conectar la
potencia de lo divino con algo real
concreto vino mucho antes mucho antes
del teatro
cuándo
cuando yo tenía 8 años mi papá tuvo un
accidente en el mar tuvo una lesión de
quinta y sexta cervical que lo dejó
cuadrapléjico esto es como un parálisis
del cuello para abajo el resto de su
vida
en ese entonces sólo 1 de cada 10.000
pacientes con ese tipo de lesión
sobrevivía
mi papá estuvo nueve meses en terapia
intensiva y mi mamá estuvo con él a mi
hermana ya mí nos llevaron a vivir a
casa de mi abuela durante ese año
escolar sin embargo
mi abuela enviudó al mes y medio del
accidente de mi papá
pasaron los meses y mi mamá luchaba por
mantener a mi papá con vida eso eso lo
entiendo claramente ahora ahí y la
admiro y le agradezco profundamente
haberse entregado de esa manera y
haberlo sacado delante igual de la misma
manera le agradezco a mi papá su fuerza
para sobrevivir y para seguir siempre
adelante de una manera positiva
proactiva constructiva usando su
circunstancia para los demás
pero la realidad que yo pasaba mucho
tiempo solo en la casa durante este
tiempo una casa en crisis que no era el
lugar para niños
donde estábamos
ahí estábamos
y los días pasaban y los días pasaban y
las cosas pasaban
cuando tienes 8 años
tú no piensas en
el contexto en las atenuantes en las
circunstancias tú solo ves dolor a tu
alrededor un dolor que no entiendes
sientes un vacío que no entiendes
yo solo quería que todo eso se acabará
y
y entonces un día me quedé con dos
cartulinas blancas que me compraban para
trabajo de la escuela
día una tarde que no había nadie en la
casa la saga de las recorte en forma de
alas
las monte en un gancho para la ropa de
sus alambre
y me sale al jardín con ellos
al fondo del jardín había dos árboles
muy viejos había un montón de piedras
que para mí a mí me parecían muy altos y
me subí en él
y me puse mis alitas de cartulina blanca
y desde ahí
le pedía a dios le pedí a diosito que me
llevara
que yo ya no quería estar ahí
espere
se lo volví a pedir
él no me escuchó
al menos eso yo creí
de adolescente me peleaba yo
constantemente con este vacío que yo
tenía me hacía incesantemente la
pregunta de por qué nos pasó a nosotros
porque a mi papá no si dios es bueno
porque esté enojado con nosotros porque
nos hace esto
pase a pensar que dios era un dios
vengativo cruel malo
y cuando me callo en las manos
un libro de nietzsche en la preparatoria
me pregunte siquiera si dios existía eso
independientemente de los hábitos
cotidianos de fe y religiosos que había
en mi familia en mi casa
hasta ese día en el blanquita
cuando esa mujer con sus dos niños me
encaró yo lo primero que pensé es quién
soy yo para darle una bendición porque
ello me parecía le pareció una
suplantación me pareció un engaño
depresión inglés daño incluso conmigo
mismo
y sin embargo
no podía dejar de mirarla
no podía
no pude huir de ella no pude sustraerme
de ella
independientemente del jalón que me ha
dado don joaquín algo en mí se conectó
con ella
me vacío
se conectó con el suyo
y de repente
ya no estábamos solos
de repente
de repente todo podía estar mejor
de repente éramos mucho más
que sólo dos personas ahí
dios estaba ahí
estaba en nosotros estaba en la fe en
esa fe qué sucede
en un instante con otro de buena
voluntad sin nada a cambio solo porque
quieres
y porque estás
si tuvieron ustedes adiós delante de
ustedes hoy que le pedirían aunque le
pedirían
aquí estoy
están los bigotes se instalaban alguien
dijo que dios era bueno no sé por qué
bueno pues eso que le pedirían
eso que me pedirían denle la vuelta a la
tortilla y ofrezcan solo a quien tienen
juntos
estoy a mejor vida en celo a quien los
espera en la casa nunca saben la
sorpresa que se puedan llevar
simplemente con decirlo en voz alta eso
es lo que me quieren reclamar a mi dios
eso busquen alguien que esté aquí en
este plano que les pueda contestar
y perdonen
siempre es tiempo
cargar con el silencio es brutal
el cine hollywoodense se empeña en
enseñarnos que los gestos de lo
milagroso de lo divino de lo mágico son
gestos grandilocuentes que merecen una
producción de 120 millones de dólares y
los mejores efectos especiales y sobre
todo son dignos de que tú pagues tu
boleto t por verlos
a veces
no basta
más que escuchar
más que mira
que están de veras
la fe esa fuerza que tanto nos hablan
está en el otro no está en ningún otro
lado
sí
muchos años después a los 35 estaba yo
haciendo la pastorela de the latter san
francisco con mis compañeros del inba
era yo para variar el arcángel miguel
por supuesto tenía yo pero en ese
entonces como para hacerlo
y nuevamente una muchacha me esperó al
final de la función
yo soy el más tardado para salir del
teatro la verdad y en esta ocasión es
tarde todavía más que la de costumbre
entonces yo seguía con mi túnica y mis
sandalias y toda la parafernalia acá y
en un descuido esta muchacha
se me acerco
me miró de frente
y los ojos se le llenaron de lágrimas
así que yo pudiera ser nada me abrazo
y me pidió perdón por haber abortado les
pedía perdón a dios por haber abortado
yo siempre he sido una persona de
pensamiento progresista yo creo
firmemente en el derecho a decidir sobre
tu cuerpo creo absolutamente
en la igualdad entre los sexos
pero en ese momento
solo le escuche
la tuve entre mis brazos todo el tiempo
que pude
y lloramos juntos
no se esperen al gesto grandilocuente
sean generosos con estar con escuchar
con un abrazo
y miren a los niños
siempre pensamos que los niños deben de
recibir de un adulto buenos consejos
disciplina educación es sí claro pero a
veces como yo
solo necesitan alguien que esté ahí para
sentir que todo va a pasar
que todo va a estar bien
que alguien los escucha
ese área
gracias por escucharme
[Aplausos]